well what's going wrong from the German
Institute for Economic Research fattenin
fischner joins us why can't Europe get
growth back up to an acceptable level
despite all of the reform and despite
all of the austerity it's been going
through well a story austerity is part
of the story obviously in the sense that
if fiscally expenditures are weak as
they currently are in the crisis
countries this obviously means that
growth dynamics will be weak but it's
only part of the story in the sense that
those countries really have to reinvent
their growth models if you think of the
case of Spain for example large part of
the growth in the past was based on
housing construction and just basically
fell apart it simply doesn't happen
anymore and in this sense they have to
completely replace what happened in the
past and create something new and this
simply doesn't help them overnight well
those national differences aren't a part
and parcel of very used problems if we
take a look at Germany Spain Italy and
Portugal for example you don't get much
different as far as growth goes in the
first quarter the graph paints an
extremely telling picture of the vast
economic discrepancies across the block
how can those very different ailments
all be effectively treated with the same
formula from the doctors in Brussels I
think it's not the same formula they are
subscribing for prescribing for for the
country's I think they look very much in
detail into what is actually going wrong
in Spain in Greece and there are
different recipes I think that's not the
case I think we have to be a bit
considerate in the sense that there are
some things which are easier dealt with
like fiscal policy for example that's
something a national government can
immediately influence while other things
reforms to the labour market for example
they simply take much longer and
therefore take much longer to have a
result but at some stage the blame has
to fall back on a technocrat see in
Brussels and it looks like that's
exactly what's happened in this election
in a way it probably happened and I
fully understand that people in the
crisis countries in southern Europe are
worried about the current situation I
worried about the labor market situation
for example I don't know if it's really
fair to blame the guys in Brussels for
that but this is certainly what happened
and and the election results in this
sense are of warning we'll have a listen
to this court the French president says
for many citizens Brussels has become
remote and incomprehensible there is a
truth to that in the sense that
democratic legitimacy for European
policy makers is very big and that is
part of the problem as well if people in
essence have the problem have the
feeling that they cannot influence what
is going on in Brussels and have to obey
two rules which are coming from Brussels
this will certainly steer uneasiness
about this current situation and EU
leaders have been preaching austerity
and yet the the monster that we know in
Brussels they don't work in one language
they don't even work in the one city I
mean very inefficient well that's also
unfair i think if you think first about
the member of civil servants deu has
much less than the german government for
example has so in a way they are not so
inefficient of course there is
inefficiency involved if you integrate
27 different countries with I don't know
maybe 24 different languages that all of
course itting induces inefficiencies but
it's in a way normal and part of this
integration process it is it normal in
Strasburg the inefficiencies their
buildings are empty for 317 days of the
year no that's probably a problem I
agree with that that we don't need this
building in Strasburg but that's again
part of the European policy making
process that the guys in front will
never accept that Strasburg is cut down
what about this feeling of leaving the
block at the moment that's being brought
up in both France and Britain could that
get stronger I guess it could get
stronger and we'll see it get stronger
in Britain definitely i'm not sure if
the results off of the phone as you know
in France are really if the if the
voters really want to tell us that they
want to leave Europe I think once this
decision comes closer they will be more
reluctant because in the end it the
losses for the respective countries will
be much bigger than for the European
Union there will be losses in world for
the European Union as well if we lose
France or it or UK it will be damaging
but it will be much worse for the
leaving countries the French say they'd
roll out the red carpet to British
investors if the UK opted out of the EU
how much would that help just briefly in
a way it would help I mean what we need
is investment in the European countries
and in particular in the crisis
countries and if it's the right
investment which helps to stimulate
reinventing those economies what we said
before then you can contribute to a to a
better performance of those countries
okay something that France could need
right now thank you very much for coming
in